[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC CHIANG: Hi.
My name's Eric Chiang.
I'm a security and
privacy product
manager at Google
focused on data deletion.
Generally speaking, Google
removes data in three stages.
Stage 1 is the deletion request.
This is when the user
issues a deletion request,
either via the Cloud
Console or via the API,
and a piece of data is
flagged for deletion.
Stage 2 is the data
removal and recovery.
Once a deletion request
is made, the data
is made inaccessible
to read requests
and it is hidden from the
product user interface.
This removal step confirms
the user's deletion request.
Some deletion requests
allow for recovery,
such as those for accounts,
projects, or a query
on BigQuery.
Stage 3 is the deletion.
If the data marked
for deletion is not
recovered within
the stage 2 window,
it is deleted in the
underlying layer of products,
such as Cloud Storage
or Cloud Spanner.
Each GCP service from
which data gets deleted
has its own detailed process
to ensure complete deletion.
This might involve
repeated passes
through the system to confirm
all data has been deleted.
After the recovery period,
GCP will broadcast a deletion
request with a unique
account or project
identifier to all subservices.
This will begin the
product-level deletion,
during which GCP waits for an
acknowledgment signal from all
the products to
complete deletion.
Most of the products within
GCP performs deletion
by overwriting.
This is done by removing the
file pointer to the data.
And once the data is marked as
deleted, the space it occupied
is marked as empty and
eventually overwritten
by new data.
Google Cloud Storage
goes one step further
by activating cryptographic
erasure, which
deletes the key that is
used to decrypt the storage
buckets before deletion
of the buckets' content
by overwriting it.
Last but not least,
let's not forget
de-commissioning of hardware.
Google meticulously tracks
the location and status
of all equipment
within our data centers
through acquisition,
installation, retirement,
and destruction, via
barcodes and asset tags.
If a component fails to pass a
performance test at any point
during its lifecycle, it is
removed from the inventory
and retired.
When it is retired, an
authorized individual
will verify that
the disk is erased
by overwriting the
drive with zeros
and performing a
multi-step verification
process to ensure that the
drive contains no data.
If the drive cannot be
erased for any reason,
it is stored securely until it
can be physically destroyed.
Depending on
available equipment,
we either crush and
deform the drive
or shred the drive
into small pieces.
In either case, the disk is
recycled at a secure facility,
ensuring that no one
will be able to read data
on retired Google disks.
To learn more about deletion on
Google Cloud Platform, please
visit our website and
read our white paper.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]